let's watch and see what happens let's
try the first one okay so if I have give
me some coordinates give me easy ones
please okay okay okay zero is you have
to do one one would that work let's just
see what happens
let's just see what happens now remember
don't go for case one first case one
first so what I'm going to do is I've
got K and I've got L right k is the
first one it's what you do first you
start it and you go away from being so
in this case I'm going to go in there
too and that makes this three let's just
see what happens we have our formula
I'll write at the top is we're gonna use
it twice we have our formula
okay I'm gonna use it once with these
values I'm going to use it again try me
on the values okay
what's going to happen um my ex wanted
my y1 they just zero one thing
okay with that ah my case are going to
be minus two
and then I need my x2 y2 which are just
one and one you care that so far have I
done this or like a by the way you can
see the way that I'm constructing this
my brain like and the way you've written
it x1 and y1 are pen you see them
together so when I'm writing out the
formula rather than going what's L okay
what's x1 okay
what's that K and so on right I do x1
and y1 together because they've been
written down to me and presented to me
together okay so that's how I'm doing
this in this kind of alternating with k
plus L it's uh yeah it's gonna be three
plus negative 2 and negative 2 plus 3
which is 1 so now does this make sense
does it make sense let's draw a really
rough picture and see what we're getting
okay there are a and B and it's telling
us that p is all over here at negative 2
negative 2 that's what's saying isn't it
okay so that's does its match does this
match our our our external division is
this - in comparison to this 3 it is
right it looks good to me
okay so this has landed us on the right
spot okay what would happen what would
happen if we switched it around okay so
this was on this is case 1
okay let's do case two this time what am
I gonna do my points are the same points
the same but instead of I'm negative two
I have positive two and set a three is
negative three
what difference will it make
well let's have a go here we go my ex
wonder why I want it's still the same so
I've still got zero and zero that okay
now when I do K it's just positive 2
which is exactly the negative what I
have here right - and my x2 y2 they're
also the same one and one what's
happening on this node is what's
different it's dead of one right I've
got 2 minus 3 now which is so I'm
getting minus 2 minus 2 now why is it
that like switching signs here is okay
whereas switching the order of these two
numbers is not okay you can see why
now what I would suggest to you is I'm
not gonna tell you yet so I think it's I
mean in some ways the answer doesn't
matter or you need your members you can
do it either way just put a minus sign
on one of them okay what I would suggest
to use to remember this gradient
gradient what's the gradient formula
tries every one right correct
okay now which point is which and it's
huh
it doesn't matter right but why doesn't
it matter
I will let you everything go back when
you answer that question of why it
doesn't matter here you have the answer
to this question of why it doesn't
matter which one is negative okay when
you're dividing externally you'll get
given the numbers like this positively
okay
keep your the same that's gonna match
what you start this is gonna match in
how you finish okay now put a minus sign
on one of them that's it and again
foolproof way throw yourself a diagram
it doesn't have to be beautiful it just
has to be close enough that you can see
your ratios are roughly right okay